all right guys
bang bang i've got jeff here with me
thank you so much for doing this awesome
to be here
thanks all right we got a lot to cover
so let's just start with kind of the
basics of
inflation versus deflation how do you
describe that to people
i take a pretty simple outlook and i
just say inflation is when your money is
worth less over time
goods and services go up in relation to
your money and deflation is the opposite
your money is worth more over time and
goods and services
go down in value against your your money
the entire world that we know today
exists based on an inflationary system
so the money is devalued
meaning that goods and services the
price of those go up over time
it's pretty much common knowledge right
and uh also accepted by the majority
that that is how the system
should work i think you've got a very
different opinion
i tend to be sympathetic to your view of
the world but maybe just describe like
what are the
issues with that inflationary system and
then why do you think that there's
actually a different system that could
be better
well um we've always go you're right
we've always grown up in an inflationary
system
and it's worked well for the majority of
population
my parents house went up in value
they paid back that debt with cheaper
money than they earned more throughout
their life and so
on that path it sounded like a good
thing
we were taught in school inflation is
required
um and and this is what some of the
stuff that i explored in the book
but then that system is bumping up
against technology
so we've always lived in a system we
measure everything from that system that
we're in
and then that system is bumping up
technology wanting to bring down prices
really fast wanting to do and what does
technology do
whether it's a ceo that puts technology
into the company whether it's you using
technology
technology does more for less right no
ceo puts technology in their company to
make
prices go higher they do it to give you
more for less or to compete
in an open market to to drive more value
to you you use technology for the same
reason
and so when you add up what's happening
with technology
bumping into this force of inflation
that that is really man-made
just create created man-made inflation
that
you you ask how could those two systems
work together
so you have the technology being a
deflationary force
meeting the inflationary force of money
and central banking
and now when they meet you're saying one
has to
override the other okay what is the
um legacy system and the people who are
proponents of the inflationary system
do they believe that the inflationary
system will be the overriding force
there
or do they actually think that the
deflationary force is greater
i you know it's hard to ask what every
single person
wants or doesn't but what i would say is
most people are trapped in a system and
they have no
idea that there could be a totally
different system that produces better
outcomes
they have no clue because they live in
the system they measure their house
prices by the system they measure the
food prices by the system
they measure everything by the system
and they in that system
requires prices to always go up forever
in perpetuity um and because
that system is built on credit and that
crit and that credit
if prices start to fall would unwind
because nothing's backing the credit
it would keep unwinding and so if you
allowed deflation to happen in that
existing system
it unwinds to the ground so i
you borrow money from me somebody
borrows money from you and everybody
thinks the other person is safe
but when it starts unwinding it's just
the counterparties
move all the way it goes all the way to
the sand
and there's nothing backing it it's just
credit backing it
and so credit in a deflationary system
gets more expensive and can't be repaid
so that's really the that's that's
really the problem with these two
systems
but they're diametrically opposed and so
what governments are doing
they're trying to print more money
change the rules of
free markets and become and centralize
markets essentially to print more
money to pretend that system still works
and it has dramatic consequences this
entire credit based inflationary system
it's basically a confidence game yeah
well
to a point so so again let's go it
worked and it drove a lot of value to
society
for for a long time yes other countries
if you looked at the u.s other countries
didn't it didn't work for and everything
else but with the
with the reserve currency it worked it
drove a lot of
value for the economy it just it can't
work
going forward okay what what is the
impetus
or the kind of milestone that changes it
did work
but now it can't work so it always if
you go if you if you break it down
you and just ask yourself why do i want
my money to get be worth less each year
that that question kind of deserves an
answer
because i don't think personally any
single person wants their money to be
worth less each year but when they roll
it up into a system they think that
that's a good thing
so so first but but
so inflation is just a hidden tax
so so governments don't want to tell you
the truth about the services that you
want
and and what they need to pay for them
so they hide it into end
inflation so because tax rates would go
way higher
um um without without inflation and so
inflation is a hidden tax but it's a
hidden tax on the most vulnerable part
of
society um so it's it's a for
somebody like me with lots of assets
it's
i it's a windfall the debt gets
less value less and the assets go up my
rents go up on houses and everything
else so it's a windfall
what you're describing real quick just
for people who are listening is
um there are if we separate a population
let's say the united states
and we break it into 20 so top 20
percent next 20
all the way to the bottom 20 of
americans at some point
there is uh let's say the top 50 percent
have uh investable assets they have
non-cash
right where they store wealth the bottom
50 again general number
they don't have that and so all of their
wealth is in dollars
and what you're basically saying is that
when the dollars are devalued
the people with the assets are
benefiting it's a good thing right
that they're encouraging if they're
cheering it on the people at the bottom
though are actually having the
exact opposite effect they're seeing
their wealth hit harder and harder with
that
invisible tax and actually becoming
poorer and poorer and and if it was
50 50 that would be one thing but but
the wealth inequality when you look how
bad it is
it's way worse and it's people measure
income inequality it's
it's wealth inequality it's it's
actually what you just said it's the
assets
so just imagine you're having one house
and the house goes up in value
and you're living in the house now you
have two and somebody but your
your neighbor has two houses and both go
up and
and the rents go up so somebody on the
other side of the equation
the renter is paying a whole bunch more
their money went down in value yours
went up
now imagine you're blackstone and you
have
hundreds of thousands or millions of
houses that you're renting to a whole
bunch of people
it's it's a massive wealth transfer to
the to the rich
um and so the more you have more
investable assets
real estate stocks everything else that
is
just a staggering wealth transfer to the
risk
but but again going back to it why do we
need it
why why do we actually need inflation if
you just go to
first principles and before we go into
it won't work anyways
because technology is a stronger force
why do we need it
and and who says that inflation is
required who says that you have to
devalue your money
or hide taxes in inflation
to be able to thrive as a society seems
it seems like
that's worth a question or worth an
answer worth an answer and i don't see
an answer for it
what do you think their answer would be
even if it's not a good one okay so what
i know now
um is these two systems because because
the system would fail spectacularly
without
inflation and without where do we go to
so so system changes require something
to move to we'll talk about bitcoin a
little bit
as well but what what happens from the
existing system
let's say you're in government pump what
do you do
do you just say okay game's over game's
over
let's stop stop printing because if you
do
every single bank collapses every single
institution collapses
that there's chaos on the streets as the
as what should have happened a long time
ago
kind of overriding free market force
for forces it wouldn't have looked like
this now but now because
because governments have kicked the can
down the road so so far
that now it would be a complete and
utter collapse global
global collapse and so it's
it's a they're stuck they're stuck in a
corner
right now from the existing from the
existing system
and and i think what what was happening
and this is why technology
if we go on the other side the other
system what
what's around us all the time and we
don't know but we don't
notice how fast it's moving is this
technology impact
like my phone used to just be a phone
remember
it was only 2007 that the iphone was it
came out
and think of what you have for free on
your phone today
from photos to everything else to it's
it's just all
abundance more and more for less out of
your phone
it's it's community it's it's everything
now it's going to be your ai device it's
going to be a whole bunch of
things and that that is a bigger impact
going forward so most of the so that
what that sets up is you're in a in a
macro deflationary in
a world with
government printing trying to stop it
but
if you go backwards in time you can see
actually the evidence of what i would
what i'm saying in time so
kind of when i wrote the book there was
185 trillion dollars of
of new money so to call it stimulus
credit creation
to create 46 trillion dollars of
economic growth over the last 20 years
and what i think has happened is this
we've actually not had we should have
had
with technology two or three percent
deflation per year or disinflation per
year that's what the natural course
would have would have done and instead
of allowing the natural course so
your your things everything around you
would be
getting less and less expensive and
and it wouldn't take as much labor so
you wouldn't need as many jobs to be
able to do that as things
fell out of price but instead of
allowing that to happen because
and it isn't not bad people
bad incentives on the existing system to
kick the can down the road
we can grow our way out of that so
interest rates come down
that we'll we'll create a bunch of money
when we can't pay the bentley
back we're gonna we're going to print
money instead
instead to pretend we can pay it back um
and so that two percent cut two or three
three percent natural rate of deflation
that's moving forward is is being offset
with with inflationary or trying to
print money and so now you're out
if you if you looked at you're out here
and the fall to where the natural market
would look like
it's getting worse it would be
staggering so and what that means is
the further we go down this path because
technology is not moving slower
it's moving so again most of the
deflation is in front of us
the further we go down the path the
further we kick the can
the more we kick down the can down the
road and the worse the consequences are
is there a point in time or a milestone
that
you can't kick the can further down the
road because i think most people
generally think if they understand kind
of even at an elementary
uh you know level okay a lot of what
we're doing with bailouts and
inflation and this stuff is we're just
pushing the problems further ahead
yeah we're making a little bit worse but
uh at that time we'll address it you
even hear the federal reserve at times
talk about
you know we're not worried about
inflation in 2020 when if inflation
shows up we'll deal with it at that
point we have confidence that we'll be
able to do that then
is there a point where just there is no
more kicking the can down the road and
it's like kind of like d-day like
he just we got to deal with it today and
it's not pretty you
you've heard gradually then suddenly yes
yes that's how markets
that's how markets work and a lot of
things don't i use that example in the
book i think we talked about it before
blockbuster
9000 stores netflix different way of
different market and blockbuster put
candy aisles in their stores and had one
of their
best years because the candy the year
before they went bankrupt
so it and it's just it was crazy crazy
and you'd look at those
executives in blockbuster and you said
how couldn't they see it
that's what that's actually the most
important part
it is not typically not bad actors
people trying to hurt you or anything
else
in this in in the system it is the
system itself
trying to do whatever it can to protect
itself and
and you could put any different
president in
you could put any different the system
itself is built in a way
to to to reinforce it and the entire
structure reinforce
reinforces that so it requires a system
change to get to the other side and i
and
and this has huge implications
huge implications for actually it
how humanity moves forward
and because because the consequence of
continuing kicking the can down the road
like this
it kind of raises up
you can see the homeless you can see the
p so
some people are hurt by it some people
are helped by it and it
and it puts the electorate in a spot
that will overthrow the uh uh the
government and
and and but but again overthrow the
government
thinking that it's a person
and and it's just a consolidation of
power
when you think about um
the system itself
it feels very weird that one
the people who are in charge of the
decisions they get made with
the monetary kind of experiment
they are appointed not elected i
actually don't know if that
matters or not if they would make any
different decisions or if there would be
the disruptive candidate like
trump was to american politics or
whatever kind of the outlier
or if it would just we would elect the
person anyways because they worked at
some bank and we think they're smart
but then also too is it's a very very
small group of people
that are making these decisions that
affect 330 million americans
inside the united states and however
many else you know around the world that
use the dollar as the
reserve currency but what you're really
saying here is it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if they're elected or
appointed it doesn't matter if it was
five people or a hundred people making
the decision
the system is the system and they're
actually doing exactly what the system
needs them to do to continue to
perpetuate the system that we live in
and why we didn't see it as fast as
before
why we never actually asked the question
is inflation a hidden tax or is it a tax
what um is because it happened so slowly
in it 20 30 50 years ago
it was happening slower because
technology people talked about
demographics they talked about in
economics they talked about all of the
other things about
okay supply chains are moving overseas
and and then that's
disinflationary or demographics is
disinflationary
but we're driving inflation against it
but it's happening
it was happening a lot more slowly
than what you would suspect would happen
with technology
an exponential movement of technology i
used this on your last show but the
folding of the paper 50 times and
folding a paper on itself 50 times
reach a piece of paper will reach the
sun on fold 50.
and and and on on moore's law we're on
fold 34.
so and and so you start to you start to
think what does fold 35 look like what
is
when we think about self-driving cars
and ai and we're looking now
historically looking backwards and we we
think we're looking forwards on this
exponential pattern
we're not so if it required as much
printing
to be able to pretend the world's the
system still works
to today what's it going to require
going forward
and so it's just these two systems are
incongruent together they don't work to
get together
the new system is required for sure
technology is not slowing down
um and so so then you start to look into
gdp what's
ask an economist to measure the gdp
output
of of all of the all of the
pictures you use on your phone right
like think of what that's done for you
and how many
photos you take and curate and edit and
everything yourself at it
compared to what kodak and the entire
industry looked like before
or or in comments to measure i
i used to spend i i remembered spending
19.99 for a record
a record um or then a cd there used to
be record stores and cds
now i spend ten dollars a month for
unlimited music
these things are deflationary and
they're all around us yet we don't
notice it because we're we're
we're living in a system that's trying
to eradicate those gains
by the way those prices i just said are
with the inflationary impact
what would they be without it so that's
one of my big questions
is let's say that there was somebody who
was incredibly forward thinking
incredibly intelligent maybe even came
from the future
and they were running uh kind of all
central bank activities
uh and they decided you know what i'm
not going to play the game
right i'm actually going to allow
technology to run its course
and go into this deflationary
environment what would be
different about today if had this had
started in the 70s or 80s
right is it one dollar would be able to
buy a whole house like like literally
the money would be so much more valuable
and therefore
uh you would be able to exchange it for
other assets is it
that technology actually would be
further along in our lives would look
like the technology utopias that you see
you know in sci-fi movies or just like
what would be different
well even uh keynes who's ridiculed and
everything else today and and because a
lot of his policies have been turned
into
what we see now can eat keynesian but he
predicted in a 1930 essay
the economic possibilities of our
grandchildren that we'd be working 15
hour weeks
by now and and again technology saves
time it would
technology does more for less and the
output of that is
you get more for less and your time
increases
and and but because that hasn't been
followed and because we've warped
monetary policy
to be able to stop that essentially
we're creating slaves
right so a whole bunch of people on most
wheels trying to
to work harder and harder to get more
share of the pie
take take bigger bets more gambling
in into economics too to be to to try to
to try to outpace this devaluating
devaluation of currency that system can
go on for a long time
so you asked about when does it stop it
can
be i think people get confused
and they think okay we're
remember the macro trend is deflation
that is what we should want if we want
an abundant future
that is what we we should want the
the policy result is is inflationary and
people are going to say
in the well these two systems are
competing against each other
everybody's going to want more handouts
they're going to want more money
ask trying to try to get elected and as
a government saying no
here's what we're going to do we're
going to turn off the taps good luck
right
suicide mission suicide mission and so
you have to expect
that that'll that'll happen but so will
the negative externalities of those
decisions
those negative externalities typically
what happens is
is war and revolution and then a reset
of a currency that's
if you go through history that's what it
looks like um and
and that path is that that's what that
would lead lead to
because the existing system cannot deal
with
where we are in technology today or the
amount of debt to pay it back so it has
to devalue it
but but it can so
so a lot of people think that we're
going to go go into hyperinflation right
now
i disagree completely because the market
forces
and i know it looks like it right now
because of all the printing before
and that and that inflation can unless
printing
is is moving up all the time
to match the deflation deflationary
deflationary
impact of technology is moving up all
the time so more and more and more
you're not going to and then at some
point you could break the currency
and move into hyperinflation but but
think about what's going to happen next
year at this time so lumber prices were
up three times
housing prices are up and everything
else so next year at this time
when they reference the rate if lumber
prices aren't that high
that's gonna be more deflation right and
you're going to have to print more to be
able to make things go up
go out go up higher is the whole system
is a feedback loop do you think that the
federal reserve can stop
printing in terms of where we are today
so
chronovirus happens there's economic
uncertainty
right one moment then there's kind of
panic chaos liquidity crisis
all hell breaks loose in markets uh i
remember explaining to somebody march of
2020 there was only days people were
walking around and like zombies in new
york city right just like what is going
on in these markets
fed steps in central banks around the
world they print trillions of dollars
and it's all done from uh we are going
to be responsive to
the economic chaos liquidity crisis
we're gonna do everything we possibly
can to not only stabilize markets but
actually reverse the
fall of these assets and head the other
direction
they then decide multiple times in the
united states
since then do it again in various forms
whatever
their belief the entire time has been
inflation wasn't going to happen in
terms of high levels of inflation
we're getting increasing levels of
inflation right now there's a belief
that it's transitory
is there a world where they just say hey
look eventually we kind of run out of
the impact of what we've already printed
we don't print anymore
and therefore you know we're kind of
back to the nor back to normal or back
to the old day
no or is it just here we go again
they're gonna print more later this year
and more next year or more the year
after so
so that's actually why you need to look
at the trend line or we should look at
the trend line and what
what is what's technology telling us
what's the
inflation or what's the policy to
telling us
and so remember if they allow deflation
everything unwinds and the unwind would
be severe
just like in 2008 the unwind would have
been severe right but the
the the amount of printing required in
2008 to stop
small it was 250 billion and small
remember the marches on wall street
and everything else 800 billion it
started at 250 billion and it went to
800 billion and now
we'd laugh at that number 800 billion
it's changed
there's a scene i i'd literally uh wish
we should clip it at some point and just
i should tweet it
uh there's a documentary called panic
there's a documentary called hank
and both of them involved many of the
players in the uh financial crisis
and at one point uh pink paulson i think
is in panic
is like i knew that we needed 700
billion but i knew i couldn't go in
there and
say that number so instead i went in and
said we don't know yet you know what we
needed but
whatever and he's kind of like laughing
about it and like 700 billion would be a
discount compared to you know they just
printed two trillion
literally a decade later and and then a
bunch more
and and so what will happen this could
stabilize things for a little not
without the
negative externalities um but then the
next
uh then the next will cost way more
it'll
it happens every single time there's any
sort of economic uncertainty or chaos or
any sort of disruption in the market of
just prices go up
um it goes back to this idea of uh being
addicted right the economy is addicted
to the stimulus it has to have it and
every time it needs a bigger shot
of the stimulus in order to see the
impact that it needs and so
you used to get tens of billions you got
hundreds and they got trillions
eventually we're gonna get 10 plus
trillion dollar stimulus packages the
future so 185 trillion
over the last 20 years before before
covert before when i wrote the book
produced 46 trillion dollars of economic
return globally
now that now it's going to take a lot
more than that
to produce more growth and the same
thing is going to happen in other
it's it's just a shell game yep so so
we've lost control of what the currency
is and and that
that is forcing people to ask wait
if you can just make up money at this
rate why am i paying taxes
why am i and and so it's forcing more
people and that's i think what's
happening in bitcoin too
it's forcing more people to take a
deeper look at their understanding of
how the game's played and and and why is
the game played that way
is there some law is there some physics
law that
requires the game to be played like that
and we don't and then we realize
oh really what's the new game or what's
the
future game that as people go and look
at and ask those questions
they seem to be gravitating towards
there is a different way a deflationary
type environment
that could be successful so that's what
i think it is
and i i think that that's the only way
that's congruent with
kind of humanity moving forward um
and and i've and i've looked
through all of the different kind of
plausible outcomes on the other and
i'm going to simplify this i think this
is where we're at
we're in a world right now which is most
people don't realize it because they're
measuring the system from the existing
system and they think
okay i can i i'm still okay i am
i'm not as rich as that person but i'm
still okay
um and and so most people are living in
this uh
this system while the system right uh
breaks
not realizing that it's consolidating
control
at an alarming rate so when you do you
don't you either have
two spectrums right and i won't go all
the way
probably if i was to
i'm going to simplify it but there's
nuance between here
you have free markets or you have
dictators and or centralization
and and through lots of experiments
through history we see how
centralization ends in kind of the
biggest thug
and so if you remove free markets you
you tilt and you move on a path in a
cascading path because people
are short-term bias per our own personal
short-term buyers for most people's will
will vote for the person
that thinks they'll give them the most
right now and
in that center and that centralizes so
the great theme right now is
is we have centralized economies
and and what i worry about is because
this is the path we're on
is centralized economies with um
with ai and robotics and everything else
that that look pretty dystopian if
if it's hard for people to rise up
against dictators today in their
countries can you imagine rising up
against a dictator with
drones that can 20 exactly exactly
and so so and and or we have
decentralization and hard money
that is a forcing function to to
let up a free market or more free market
work
when you think about that new world
one of the things that's the most
interesting to me is in the old world
abundance does not get passed on to
the civilization in the new world you do
this framing of deflation and inflation
is
antithetical in some way to what a
traditional keynesian economic
you know kind of disciple would say or
even the mainstream media frankly
where their belief is that you need
inflation in order to get velocity of
money if you don't have velocity of
money you can't possibly have an
abundant
civilization and so why do you
think and are likely right that the
deflationary environment actually
creates a more abundant future
rather than this inflationary one that
needs that velocity of money
so so if we measured
where i'm going to the this there's
gonna there's gonna be chaos on the
chain and the system change
no matter what but the system change is
coming no matter what
on as the system moves forward
didn't when i grew up we wanted to save
our money so we could buy more tomorrow
and if and if if i saved money and there
was a
an event and everything
prices fell i actually took more of the
gains
right that's how economy work works risk
risk return
so today in the existing world we
essentially you have a no-lose bet
for for if you're hedge fund and
everything else or your bank you
nope no problem no there is no
consequences of bad actors
versus a system that change uh changes
but more importantly to the then more
importantly than that
is a lot of the things that we used to
buy as
things are being digitized and those
things
so we use you use the example records
use the example of um
we can see that all around us but it's
just starting so 3d printing is going to
change
complete supply chains and around things
like this in this office this table
everything else
and it will be printed in your home and
it's really all it is is
it's information that has been organized
those atoms have been organized in a
physical world
and that information is going to move
from your head or ai
into a 3d printer and it's going to be
organized at your home
and you're going to have abundance in
time that might take
another 10 years it might take another
15 years but that is coming
and there's nothing that the existing
system can do to stop that from coming
and they go up a level the more they
the more the existing system kind of
inflates
what would a rational ceo do if they
can't
if they can't find if labor is going up
in price
and technology can remove that labor
rational ceo is going to
to exactly this is my favorite example
they've literally replaced some of the
cashiers with touch screens
yeah and and but that that's just start
that's just starting and it
and and by the way why do they do that
it's not because
they're bad people it's because you as a
shopper wouldn't shop there if they had
to raise the prices to pay for everybody
because we live in a competitive
environment so the incen
the incentive system is is
right now the incentives are aligned to
a broken model
and if the incentives were aligned to a
free market model
you would see prices falling and you'd
see you'd see your time increasing
the prices would fall so far so fast so
fast and they would keep falling after
that so
and let's i often get the example or the
question
what um what about a market that keeps
really high margins you have a monopoly
that take keeps really high margins
what do you think would happen with a
whole bunch of entrepreneurs you're an
entrepreneur i'm an entrepreneur
if i saw fat margins in technology being
able to provide better outcomes for
people that's the market i would attack
first
yep incentive shopping center incentives
change every
everything yeah as we're watching this
happen
forget bitcoin and sound money and all
this
we already see technology is eating the
world right
and it's happening uh in a very real way
very miserable way
it's been happening for a long time this
is not a new thing either right it's
just
uh in some weird way the horse to the
car was technology
eating the world um but what we do see
along the way
is what i will call the uh
pure capitalists with
people who are interested in other
things right so whether it's the esg
crowd whether it's some sort of climate
change whether it's some sort of
other thing that is not just pure
economic incentives
drive the world free markets drive the
world let the system play
out and this is where we're going are
they ultimately on the wrong side of
history and what i mean by that is not
so much that they
their causes don't matter or their
claims aren't
factual in some way but it's the free
market is going to be the greatest
referee or the greatest kind of driver
of progress
not you know mandates and some of this
other stuff like how do you think about
something so no
if unless you centralize everything okay
explain
so if you believe 12 people could
control every
every interaction in the economy or or
the government you elect control
everything
and they will always do it in your best
interest rather than their best
interests
then you should centralize you should
really want centralization
but what ends up happening is even if
somebody the more
that lord acton quote uh power corrupts
and absolute power crops absolutely
the more power that somebody has over
your decision-making process
the more uh the more it's it's a gain
and power in a loss for you
and that that changes you know once it's
caught once it's concentrated like that
you'll lose everything you will
literally lose everything so free market
isn't perfect
but it is the best system it it is the
best system
today so that is the path of
centralization that's what it'll look
like
and so the people closest to the
government similar to what it looks like
today
right get more of the gains and
everybody races into the government
to to protect that if you look look at
russia
look at china look at look at what it
they
look at what economies like that look
like and if you want that here
you'll you'll want centralization what's
up guys before we continue with this
interview
i want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin ethereum
and many many more kraken also provides
in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today again that's kraken.com
bang bang all right let's get back into
this interview i hope you're enjoying it
i forever have used an example of what
is the difference between the person who
uh is the blue collar worker at a
corporation who has to move up the
ladder right get
more into a position of power for
economic gain and kind of the
egotistical return on having control and
power and all stuff
and a regular citizen who's essentially
the blue-collar worker equivalent
who wants to then move up into some sort
of position of government power right i
mean it's a very
similar type of of uh of mechanic
now as we go through this transition
there's this belief that um
centralization is bad i think you and i
both would agree
with that and i think history would
suggest that that is definitely true
uh historically there's been maybe a
line in the sand
the government was responsible for some
portion of our lives
whether we wanted it or not that was
just part of what they did
but it does feel like it is becoming
more and more expansive
in their uh mandate right in their eyes
and so now all of a sudden uh monetary
policy is becoming
politicized in a lot of ways maybe it
always has been it just wasn't so
obvious
but is that the natural progression also
of government power as it just kind of
continues to creep further and further
and further into your life and history
suggests that eventually it
is essentially planned kind of communist
driven or socialist driven
not not not necessarily okay um but
but on the trend we are on on on
unsound money when when governments have
control over money and can inflate
every that's that's where it takes you
because people always vote
for for i want because they need more
they need more it's not so much that
they're
even greedy it's a pure survival so so
so think about this so should housing be
is
number one you'd ask us over the last 20
years 185 trillion dollars
if you didn't if you didn't increase
if you didn't create 185 trillion
dollars
would housing prices be as high as they
are today
probably not if you didn't print as much
money
recently would housing and real estate
look like it looks like today the answer
is no it wouldn't
okay so a whole bunch of people one note
of that bet
now rents are a lot higher and a whole
bunch of people lost out of that bet
so a lot of the people that are
demanding more money
i need minimum wage to go up i need i i
i need free money i need government
subsidies are doing it because they
can't pay the bills
because government reached in and made a
whole bunch of prices higher that they
can't afford
and so so that's that's kind of why you
get once you start to get to this
this system change change you get
revolution at some point
um weimar republic the rise of hitler
was a result of the very same explain
what happened in weimer republic
uh so uh world war one
they couldn't pay their debts the u.s uh
uh uk demanded uh reparations
payback for world war one they couldn't
they went through a period of hyper
uh hyperinflation just print money to be
able to pay back the debt and
cheaper uh currency um
hitler started gaining power in that
beer pro he actually as a revolution as
a revolutionist
he he actually got put in jail through
trying to overthrow
the government in i think 1924-1925
dawes plan came in and said okay we're
going to give you more time
to pay this back and discount some of
this from
from from kind of other other countries
including the
us and then
and that fixed it for a while kicked the
can down the road for a while
and then 1929 in this
in the states it started depression
kind of a global depression
there as well so now we go back to
hyperinflation so we print
print more money a whole bunch of people
that and and
looks ex similar at a different
at a different level than what's
happening today but a whole bunch of
people are enriched by that printing
and then a whole bunch of people are
killed by that
that printing and so those people that
are hurt
go and look for a revolutionist that and
what does
that person do typically they'll blame a
person or a group of people and say
it's not your fault it's their fault
they're the reason
that it looks like this and and it's
believable
they've taken your freedom they've taken
you for it exactly
exactly and it's believable so so that's
how
that's how you have a revolution or
system change and then
hitler essentially changed constitution
and everything else to
keep power and we know the rest of that
history
i often ask why don't why didn't people
as they saw these signposts
similar signposts that we see today why
didn't they leave
why didn't the rich people leave germany
and
and the the simple reason is because all
of their currency was denominated
there their real estate was denominated
there and and
and they didn't see the real tale risk
was the social
revolution and the revolution that was
coming that was the tail risk
and so they they stayed in they and and
and and what are you going to do you're
going to you can't take your real estate
with you you can't take your money
you're not going to take suitcases money
with you on a plane
so or boat um and so they get stuck
and that's and that's typically what
happens bitcoin today
allows us it's a little different you
remember 12 words you can move any
anywhere you're not going to take your
memory and uh
and and so so so so i think
even just this alone with all of the
science posts
before we get into why it's so so
important
just if you looked at it through that
lens alone
it is a must own asset it is a must own
where what's what's going on in the
world today
when you start to kind of unpack um
bitcoin itself how much of your
excitement or even sympathy for the
asset in terms of
why you holding your portfolio is
economically driven
from like uh macroeconomics i have to
have this to protect my wealth
versus more of the social and political
stuff which is
you know if i need to move i can do it
quickly if there's unrest if there's
confiscation of assets
all that type of stuff it's a super
interesting question i haven't been
asked that before
actually for me i think i i lean more to
bitcoin because
because it it brings fairness and equity
to the world
it brings it brings a free mark free
market forces
that allow the abundance gained from
technology
to be past the broadest part possible
audience
um that's my primary reason i don't need
more money
i don't need more anything like i just
life is good
life is great um i love what i do
tons of friends tons like i love
everything i do
so so i wrote the book more because
i'm living in this system benefiting
from this
benefiting from this system
understanding that
like i couldn't understand why prices
weren't falling at the rate they
should be falling when when all of the
technology companies that i was building
were producing crazy returns for people
that's why people were using the
or using the technology companies and so
i couldn't understand why that wasn't
happening at the rate that it should be
so that's that's what i investigated so
for me personally
i'm in it more for the uh fairness
when if i now put on my investor hat
when i think about
um how much is in bitcoin how much is in
other things
my hurdle rate for for an investment in
is in say a company is really high
because
because i know what bitcoin is going to
do i know how i i
or i believe um i i believe it's going
to be
i i believe it's going to be reserved
currency i believe it's going to be a
bunch more than that in in in time
and and so i believe in in what that
will do
uh for a return rate and so i measure
every other return rate
other things that i would invest time or
against that
against that placeholder yeah walk me
through what does that world look like
bitcoin is the global reserve currency
the central banks fail they give up
they exist then they just do a bad job
like
how do you kind of see from where we are
today walk me through
maybe not a finish line but just like
you know 25 50 years from now what does
that
path look like so yeah i wrote
an article uh called the greatest game
um and it's worth because it lays out
this path and
on what happens by the way it's not a
foregone conclusion
i think there's a high high probability
bitcoin i think it's unstoppable at this
this point but i understand all the fud
and why the why people would want to try
to stop it and and if you think about
kind of attack vectors on on bitcoin
whether it's esg
and everything else which are complete
nonsense we can go into those
um i understand the attack factors
for the centralization why why there's a
bunch of people in power that think that
this is a really bad thing
and it's not a bad thing it is the best
but then i
put on how do you stop a technology
that puts in empowerment in the hands of
people
empowers people it's pr really hard to
stop
especially at the size of asset class it
already is
and how it's already built into the
rails so i
i suspect the network effect that's
happening on bitcoin
to it to
to change a lot of people's views and
and it it be a forcing function
for for what we talked about in the
existing system over time
or early people on people coming on now
and holding
now or hodling now will get more of the
share of the gains on that
if you go distant into the future i'm
into in into that but here's a question
i'm often
asked said well wouldn't you just create
new winners new losers
and it's interesting to think in a free
market on bitcoin
um the only way to hold bitcoin
is produce value for others the only way
to gain bitcoin
right so otherwise so if you wanted to
to manipulate control
[Music]
then by doing so you're distributing
your bitcoin
do it to others and you lose control so
so so it is it's congruent
to where technology is taking us
humanity everything
else in my mind and i think
going through all of the movements kind
of the
because we have a short-term bias right
we all do
and we were recency bias and and so
we'll look at
okay today it's inflation oh yes it's
going to be inflation forever
the governments are doing this china is
doing this it's going to be all over the
map and i would expect
volatility throughout this time and
on the on the way other side way less
volatility
um in the in the asset class but
i don't think there's anything
governments can do to stop it at this
point
i um i'm even cautious saying this on a
podcast
because i think about what i would try
to do
if i was desperate to stop it
i would try to make some other coin
more popular that i that that work
so so so i i i don't think we should
just i don't think we should discount
how powerful
the existing system is on our lives
currency and and
and so so um i know a whole bunch of
people in bitcoin would not let it work
but but if if if
if government went into ethereum
thinking i could
control this over time
and it ran up in price for some time in
that
that i don't think it would work i think
it would centralize again i think that's
exactly what would happen
but i understand them i would understand
the rationale
to try to find something i could
centralize
do you have thoughts around proof of
stake proof of work and kind of the
centralization of proof of stake and
just like the rich control
that's right that's why that's that's
why i think i i think bitcoin is the
only system
that's actually why it's such an
important thing for me right now i'll
sound like a fanatic or
a zealot on this but that's actually why
it's so important
if you believe in open free markets i
believe you have to do everything you
can to make bitcoin successful
because i think it's the only thing that
both has a scale
and will be decent that can't be taken
by governments
um so so there's potentially other
coins that could be regulated faster but
it um but bitcoin both has the scale
so governments didn't see it fast enough
and now it's in the hands of a whole
bunch of people
tens of millions exactly and and so
let's just get take the downside of that
tens of millions of people
those people aren't going to give it up
and it and more and more people are
kind of learning what we're talking
about now and coming in and holding
and holding and so yes there's a whole
bunch of people trading
yes there's a whole bunch of people that
that are in and out and
and now but the the hodlers and and
people that are
uh holding bitcoin and understand what
we're
saying i don't think i i i
that is the ensure we get more people
onto it for that reason
and you're going to have
decentralization forever you're going to
have a currency that empowers human
beings forever
or i don't want to say forever you have
quantum you could have
did a different change but it it it is
um it is a it might be
humanity's greatest invention and i when
when i say that um i know full well what
people
say on twitter and everything else when
they when they look back and printing
press
and internet and everything else
um but we have a habit of building on
top of other great inventions and the
next greatest
um and and and so information creates
more information and more
error correction on that information and
and
and and this uh this is a huge
breakthrough
um i i think if you look back at the
printing press and that
in the time of the printing press when
it was invented people wouldn't have
thought that was a great invention
against other inventions at the time too
so i think that's
that that's the level this is playing at
fixing money forever
you described esg as kind of nonsense um
in terms of fiat currencies and and some
of the goals
describe a little bit more about what
you mean by that so and and i want to be
careful with nonsense because
i'm in some companies and i'm i'm
chairman of
three different companies that are doing
a whole bunch in
in um less carbon or climate change and
or things that are involved things
things are
exactly but but not uh not
uh not washing not green washing
not a virtue signature exactly real
companies
that have created technology impact
that that lowers cost and
produ provides benefit uh um
so so and so there's an economic benefit
to drive the
drive and and so they're growing really
some of these companies are growing
really fast as a result and
exciting so it's not
the cli i'm not a climate change denier
and everything else
but um but so
why is it nonsense quite simply
and i haven't seen an answer for this i
ask it all the time
how do you solve climate change through
an inflationary monetary system
and and and let's poke on that so
let's use some examples so
you print a bunch of money you make
house prices go up as a result so
there's a whole bunch more jobs
in building houses and there's a whole
bunch more
uh lumber needed to put so the entire
economy
right is is actually gamed to grow
faster
to to emit more
because you're devaluing money to be
able to grow fat
go grow faster so the environmental
negative side effect is a negative side
effect
of trying to grow faster which is all
rooted from the devaluation of money
can can you grow forever on a finite
planet
right pretty simple a pretty simple
equation
yeah so why do the only people that
believe we can do that are economists
right it's it so it it's it's logical
information can grow forever and
and so as information essentially is
information
it's things become information you get
more for less
that's what's uh that's what's happening
it doesn't grow the same way that
our our notion of growth is changing
with with what's happening with uh
technology
um and and so or use oil
so to and let's let's so
today we have new energy coming on
through
solar and battery uh storage and solar
and storage
which is uh the low low some of the
lowest cost energy which is getting
cheaper at 11
a year and for a long time that took
subsidies to try to drive an industry to
try to make it
hit that that point and maybe you could
argue today there's still some
subsidies but it's close to that tipping
point
where in some regions it's the lowest
cost energy without
subsidies um and it's getting cheaper
and
and so as that's taking more of the
energy infrastructure
and it'll it drives down prices
so if energy is the number one input and
everything else
and prices are being driven down
then why are oil prices 70 dollars a
barrel or whatever i haven't looked in
and lost a little a little bit but why
are
and they're 70 barrel because you've
debased currency against oil and oil
is um is a scarce resource and so
those will go up making oil more
profitable
driving exploration and toil and
everything else
so so and all of that was caused
by printing more money so again
anybody on your podcast reach out to me
find a way
do it put it on twit twitter how how an
inflationary monetary policy
is congruent with climate change um
and i i'd debate you're saying that uh
it's impossible it's impossible for
a inflationary monetary policy to be
congruent
with esg goals and actually being
serious about creating change in the
environment it it's impossible
mm-hmm it is absolutely so so when
bitcoin
solve climate change yes yes it does
and it does explain that because you you
and i both know i've said this before as
well and people think that's a crazy
statement
so explain it and and and because it
forces it
because it forces a free market because
it forces
technology to allow technology to do its
job and save you time
and reduce prices so you're not on a
tread wheel racing
racing more and more and more through
to try to to like why do we work in the
first place
right if you if you and i'll go back to
but
but you're trying to work to be able to
say have security in your life
and to have enough things when you
retire so you're going to work 60 years
of your life to over 50 years of your
life
to retire with hopefully enough to live
the last 10 years of your life
all well knowing that the goal posts are
moving the whole time
trying to move further so if you're in
that environment what would you do
you're going to try to take risks to get
out of this
environment you're going to take you
might
lever up a whole bunch of debt at the
wrong time because central bank's
policies change to be able to try to get
off the treadmill
because you know the goal posts are
moving further and further away so so
all of the incentives are aligned for
everybody to do that to do that job
when we wouldn't need to in an exit in a
different system
the system itself would would fix that
but this syste that system is also
responsible
for all the climate change there's for
all the
climate damage and environmental damage
because it requires more
and more and more and more forever
um more things more higher prices
forever or the system collapses that's
it and
that's why i say that system collapses
imminent anyways
whether through climate whether through
centralization of government whether
through revolution is
that that there is a system change
coming bitcoin
produces i believe and by the way
when i was going through bitcoin i was
looking for anything
else to i was looking for anything that
what could be a path
to get to where technology is taking us
um that that is a plausible path
and it and it's only bitcoin
and so that um but that's it because it
allows
it allows um it allows for an equitable
world it allows for
prices to fall you're not wasting your
time on this treadmill
and the externalities of that change
means you get things for for less and it
doesn't cause the same damage to the
environment too
if you're talking about the esg yeah
when you think about the transition
is it the bad stuff has to happen in
order to
create the transition is there some sort
of
carrot that can be put out there of esg
or uh dampening the wealth inequality
gap or you know name your
uh kind of thing that people care about
that bitcoin does
fix or solve or is it just
doesn't matter and there has to be a
blowing up of the
of the existing system and the example
that i can only think of is like the
burning of the boats
yeah right the whole example of when
people would come to
the united states or go looking for new
land uh
cortez yeah yeah they would literally
burn the boats because that means we're
not going back
we got to make it work is that some
element of like the only way to actually
make the new system
successful et cetera is the burning of
the boats and that means the old system
has to kind of
have a catastrophic event it it again
it's going to have a catastrophe it's
had lots of catastrophic events it's
going to have catastrophic events that's
a for sure
but when you say it has had catastrophic
events is
2008 financial crisis a catastrophic
event your eyes
well it is because because of what it
did to
free markets okay right it changed the
rules
it essentially is it's essentially it
said there's no consequences
um for bad bats if you're high enough in
the
if you're high enough on the ladder
there's no consequences for bad bats
if you're low on the ladder and you if
you take too much of a loan
we're going to wipe you out but if
you're high enough there's no
consequence that's what it said
which is the same thing is happening
today so agreed and
you know the two things i think you and
i see eye to eye on for sure
was during 2020 uh one you're bailing
out bad businesses they're bad capital
allocators they took risk they
got caught uh why are we giving them
money basically taking bad money and
chasing you know even worse money
uh two was you can say you're handing
out money to people
all you want i don't care if you're
handing out 100 or 1200 or whatever the
number is
you're gonna drastically increase prices
that are completely offset and actually
make it worse
than handing the money out right and so
um i think
those types of things along with 2008
they're catastrophic in the sense that
they have a material impact
but the system still although maybe
rocky although
there's still kind of a cliff you know
to run off of it's still
here and so do we have to basically run
off the cliff and have like the the
complete
implosion of the system or
can we actually just transition almost
like it feels like
you transitioned then i transition then
square transition yes so that's actually
why
it's really important that you have
individuals and lots of them
acquiring bitcoin because the more
individuals the the
the more peaceful the transition will be
that's that's what you want
not hedge funds not everything else
they're part of it they're going to play
in
the game but why we want a lot of
think about the people most hurt by by
the policies
those are the people that are most in
favor of the policies and many of them
don't understand bitcoin and there's
this
there's this essentially marketing or
or that that they're stuck in a cnbc
cnn a news flow or
or fox or anything else that they don't
really see what's happening here
those are the people that need to see
what's happening here
because because they're most hurt by
this they're
bearing the consequences of this and so
getting a lot more people on board there
um i think is
is it would be really important so
that's probably one of the most
important things you think is getting
individuals
around the world to acquire bitcoin and
hold their stake in the network and that
ultimately ends up being a very great
defensive mechanism
not only for bitcoin and
decentralization
but also for the lack of kind of violent
protest and revolution
it ultimately ushers in this peaceful
transition that's
i believe so yeah one of the things that
this reminds me of is
people always ask about uh global
reserve currency status
and an idea that's fascinated me now for
a couple of years
is every single currency that was the
global reserve currency
fell and was replaced happened through
violent conflict
you have the global reserve currency as
your country i come we fight i win
i now install my currency as the global
reserve currency and we move on with the
world
over and over and over again since the
fall of rome all the way through
bitcoin is actually the first time where
having the strongest defense makes you
the most powerful
in the world right when you move from an
analog world of violent combat
to a cyber world having the stronger
defense makes you the most powerful not
having the strongest offense
and so if all of a sudden you have an
impenetrable computer network that
continues to rise it doesn't matter how
good anyone else's offense is your
defense is better and therefore you're
the strongest
and so is it the first global reserve
currency that ascends to that position
without firing a bomb a bullet i i i
think
so that's the hope that that is the hope
think about what the existing system is
doing and look at the signposts of the
existing system one
one mention i just wanted to when you
say bailouts for not
bad capital allocators just think about
the system
first and think about what would you do
as a ceo
if you uh had cash on your balance sheet
and interest rates were negative or
nearly negative
you would spend that cash somewhere
right you would acquire something you'd
do something
to be able to make sure you didn't hold
cash on your balance sheet because the
government essentially was saying
we're penalizing you for holding cash
and if you in a free market
if you hold cash and your other ceo
doesn't to he levers
levers up then you're not going to be
the ceo for
for very long so the incentives are
designed
to create the instability in the market
which then requires more bailouts
when when the instability shows now now
go back to the
um in the existing in the existing
system
so what was the year and i think until
the 2013
the deal with china was the u.s buys
china's stuff
china buys uh us treasury bonds
and then that ended in about 2013. now
now u.s doesn't have
who the growing deficit
and not enough people not enough
external financing and you're printing
money to be able to to hold
rate rates down um so where does china
put that money
wouldn't it be a rational actor in a
system
where we're we're essentially i'm you're
going to pay me back with devalued
dollars
where am i going to put my money
wouldn't you wouldn't you think a
rational actor would put their money
into
commodities that are needed for the
transition to technology
like rare earth mines and everything
else
so if you look at through the lens of
what other countries are doing
and buying up assets hard assets of
things that are needed for the
for the transition essentially things
that can't be taken away from you
the value you're that's where you're so
when you see the signposts you
certainly see the rhetoric build around
the world
around around evil empires
and everything else all caused by by
money that doesn't work right but but it
but rational actors in their own in
their own
mind what will one of those uh what will
one of
uh do you think we'll ever trust
i know for me i know the answer um
will we ever trust a country's currency
again
as a reserve currency it's not even a
country currency just a currency that is
manipulatable by people yeah exactly
will we ever trust that again
and so that's what bitcoin does it
removes the manipulation
forever one of the questions i get that
i want to end with
is in a deflationary environment when
there is chaos when there is uncertainty
when there is some sort of external
event that
provides a shock to the system and you
can't manipulate the currency
do you just allow the free market to
correct and
that kind of cleans it up or is there
other things that people will be able to
do
right because the whole idea is in the
legacy system the monetary policy
manipulation is what the solution is
whether it's good or bad that is the
solution if you take away that tool
in the toolbox what happens or do we
just not have those events
so so at first we do and people leave
her up
so look at iceland in 2008. right
greece kept on okay we're going to kick
the can down the road we need this
iceland said you lent us the money on
these terms
were writing it off right and and and
and their economy came back faster than
anybody else
else because because of that because
they took a hit
and and and came back that's what should
ha should have
that's what should happen free markets
free market self-correcting
and so so i don't think it's needed i
don't i don't believe
that that you need this
i think if you created a transmission
mechanism like this now
governments might peg currencies to this
and still have a transmission mechanism
i don't think it would work long time
uh term if they're if they ran their own
currency on top of it because that's
what would happen
they would get further and further away
and you'd have resets
but um but from a
i'd i don't think it's needed i think
the free market would solve it
and the free market would solve it in a
couple of ways first people would
increase their savings rate
to be able to take those take those
shocks they would make sure that
um and and
when the shocks happened people would be
resilient and they would
find ways faster through it yeah
i tend to agree uh before i let you go
um
where can we send people to just learn
more
from you right so i know you've got the
book i know that you've done a bunch of
content
but when you use when you meet somebody
on the street and they say hey you're an
interesting guy you've got some really
interesting ideas
where do you send them i send them to
you i send them to robert i send them to
preston
this is
that's the thing this wasn't i wrote the
uh book because it was uh the price of
tomorrow yeah
um because i cared about this problem i
and i cared a lot so i did a lot of
research and cared about the problem
and so i'll still write things and i'll
put them out
but i don't need to be again i didn't do
it to
be seen or anything i i was most of my
time is
actually in in the businesses and
everything else that i really and
uh really enjoy so my perfect world
a whole bunch of other people take the
mantle and and that's what the
beautiful thing about bitcoin is um
there are some crazy smart people
in this q a in this community
and and if you have an important message
that it'll be shared it'll be broadcast
so
for for people uh you follow a lot of
them pomp but you do a
great job here uh here and so do many of
the others
but i would just follow it for people i
would go on to bitcoin twitter
i would follow a bunch of the the the
the top people and they'll point you to
other top people
because they're not trying to control
all the things to make themselves look
good
typically they're trying to share the
best information yeah i think it's a
great piece of advice
uh and then people can buy the book uh
on the knee just amazon's probably best
yeah amazon
jeff bezos was taking all our money
exactly all right and then what is your
twitter account
uh at jeff booth all right thank you so
much for doing this everything it's
awesome
and i think everyone else learned a lot
so we'll have to do it again yeah thanks